[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so one is away what is you what does it
mean to you
[Applause]
[Music]
so next question how do you describe
Western oh okay where's scientist okay
[Music]
[Music]
not the transportation UX designers is
constantly evolving this might seem like
a new and trendy brief but this is in
fact an old-school UX design notice how
all people honest McIntosh says Comic
Sans but the artwork itself is not
composed of that particular font this is
considered a funnel or a
this solution devastated if you spot a
UX designer interacting with common
human beings it is likely or witnessing
the ritual known as a lurch the workshop
consists a small separated pact writing
as much as possible on speaking pieces
of paper this is often followed by the
pact decorating the walls are there
with these vibrant colors why they
display this sort of behavior
no one knows these rituals often include
awkwardly choreographed exercises assume
to enhance creativity amongst a tree
result is a quite extraordinary display
of human behavior
[Music]
only time will tell how many Firebird
years or maybe yet another way to track
north will come out of this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as you know so the next design so we
have five staplers comparing you should
all read this it should be so so there's
this business I try to sell something to
create some viable product its
technological society actually it
proposes council solution which
inspectors business means of course and
user means of course and
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I hid
[Applause]
so that means if you just want to take
flight
be careful proceed and so you want and
you just want to success in testicles
all things and desire understand how it
works
so that in case that sometimes even a
final failure in this situation
accepting people's because they just by
the trailer they understand things so
that we would like to show how the plan
works they would like to fly a plane
it's because we don't think about us
because we are filling out my games and
then we just paste them thinking about
in being stance
[Music]
[Music]
- box into vacations and people and
those people who actually use those and
so imagine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my stomach's is ten degrees and I'm five
years old and because Allah who died of
topic sentence ends the party struck
we're now working for six years
that's pretty spring only pasta happy
atmosphere amusement park
[Music]
so this was a energy-related restaurant
videos stopping even finance marketing
all the way to the restaurant industry
and other vendors between chief of the
people and as you can see on praising
wait for up sometimes I need to switch
to date and oriented or I don't know we
need seven dollars but even if they were
absent hours
what is busy obviously money I found
from the financial turbulence
and accuracy that need to be pleased
Belen and you are here right okay so you
didn't need to know my biggest penguins
and things on control and you can see is
quite impossible and environment off by
John we have some data lies within
networks but there are literally
hundreds of them and I can't find
anything in the moment of action
discover their worth of data telling
what I want to or these places to have
the possibility to create something
based on our historical data you know
it's way too difficult our hundreds of
variables so we saved the church
effective moving on it
[Music]
okay so as paragraph is not written in
this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's fence
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he feels he feels
[Music]
[Music]
so something's so he might
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Music]
so it would music those networks and two
disparate so what are the games
consumption
[Music]
[Applause]
so we have some ideas
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because being a designer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]